- Okay, I feel like this quickly turning
from a Buzzfeed video into
just my personal diary.
- I think it's bullshit.
- Do you think I'm prettier or something,
or anything has changed about
the way you feel about me?
(rock music)
- [Narrator] Pheromones
are chemical messengers
produced by the body like sweat or oil
that elicit a behavior
or physiological response
from other organisms.
And it's thought that
they might play a role
in human attraction.
So we decided to buy some online
and ship them to the office.
- This week we're going
to be trying pheromones
to see if we can attract people,
so that should be interesting.
- I'm interested in trying pheromones
because I'm still looking for a husband.
- I am single and I'm looking
for something more regular.
- I'm curious to see if my
husband likes me a little more.
If I get a random text of
like, "Hey girl you up?"
or something like that.
- I'm a self-proclaimed Tinder queen,
but in person I just sort of like
turned into a little clamshell.
I might as well try give me a little
boost of confidence.
- Ah.
- It smells like middle
school locker room.
- So I'm going to put some on right now.
(upbeat music)
I'm going to vlog this week
to see how people treat me
differently or maybe not.
- If anyone gives me prolonged eye contact
or flirts with me or like
give me heart eye emoji vibes
because I need to know.
- It's day one of wearing the pheromones
and I'm very excited.
So we'll see if it's actually
going to do anything.
Have people come up to me.
Have people smell me,
have people want to try and kiss me.
That's what I think is going to happen.
- Okay, so I did three experiments.
One was to see if a cute
guy in a coffee shop
that I kind of make eyes with sometimes
was going to notice me.
So specifically with
this coffee store guy,
I feel like we have a flirtation.
Maybe I'm making that up, not quite sure.
Definitely want to test
out this stuff today.
We'll see, hmm.
- So I just got home to see
if Paul thinks I'm more attractive.
Do you find me more attractive today?
- Of course.
- No, for real.
- You're shorter.
- So I guess it's not working yet.
- Update, he was there,
and he went out of his
way to say hi to me.
But then he called me buddy.
Don't know what that means.
Don't want to be called buddy ever.
- I went to dinner last
night with a gal pal
and it honestly made me
a little uncomfortable
how well it was received by her.
My one friend grabbed my hand
and spent a little bit of time with it.
I think maybe if I were a straight man,
that could be seen as like a success.
- I'm officially ready
to go out on the town
and I will be putting it on,
probably dosing a lot on it
to see if anyone at the
bar tries to talk to me.
No one talked to me.
A guy was sitting literally next to me
playing an iPhone game
instead of talking to me.
- It's day three of
wearing the pheromones,
and I think it's bullshit.
I have not had anyone come up to me
being like, "Oh my god,
you smell sexy and amazing,
"I want to have sex with you."
Maybe that's not what
it's supposed to be for.
I don't know.
- Last night was a total bust.
No one hit on us.
I'm beginning to lose hope for this stuff.
- We were cooking dinner together
and I really wanted the avocado.
So I'm going to try to convince him
to go out and get some.
I don't think he wants to go out,
but I'm going to put some pheromones
and try to work my charm.
- Going to grab a quick workout,
see if I can capture a couple of boys.
- He's going to go get me an avocado
because I wanted one.
And he's usually not this nice.
Yay pheromones.
- I'm just leaving the gym.
And one of the coaches who is a female
actually asked if something was different.
They've both been girls
so maybe it's working.
Just maybe not specifically
for my personal objectives.
- I'm officially going on a date
so we're going to see if
this works for science.
- It is day five of this
pheromones experiment
and nothing has happened.
I just reek of like man cologne.
If anything I feel like
fewer people are noticing me.
- I forgot to check back
in after my date last night
and it was great.
I don't know if it was my smell.
In fact I specifically asked
if my smell hand anything
to do with our chemistry or whatever.
And he's like, "You smell nice."
So I'll take it.
- You don't love me a little more?
- I mean of course I love you more
because everyday I love you more.
- Oh that's a lie.
- Did attract some female attention.
Not my preference.
Straight men go run and tell.
- My week with the pheromones
was my week as normal.
No one came up to me on the street.
No one was dying to go out with me.
No one hit on me at the gym
and it's happened before
without the pheromones, so.
- Nothing incredible that
people like off the street
were like, "Gosh, like come here."
Which I was hoping for.
- I'm going to say that my
results were inconclusive.
The coffee shop he did notice me,
but he called me buddy.
Two, going out to the bar, no
one came up and talked to me.
Third one was the Tinder date
which I think went really well.
- So I don't think this
pheromones actually worked.
I don't think you need
to put essential oils
all over you to be
attractive to other people.
If you're around people
that make you feel good
that radiates and people are like "Wow."
- Make one person smile
and an entire room smile.
That's how you are beautiful
and that's what makes you awesome,
and that's honestly what
keeps the men flocking.
- Also alternative theory,
this ginormous blue coat just
gives me a lot of attention.
Who knows?
(acoustic guitar music)